ونحييكم من جديد في السودان هدنه جديده
لمده خمسه ايام بين المكونين العسكريين
هذه الهدنه جاءت ضمن المساعي الصعوديه
الامريكيه الهادفه لاعاده البلاد الى بر
الامان وضمان وصول المساعده الانسانيه
للمدنيين في وقت يتم فيه التفاوض على وقف
النار طويل الامد في البلاد بيان مشترك
للرياض وواسطه افاد بان طرفين اتفقا على
مناقشه وقف اطلاق النار طويل الامد قد
يلزم او قد يستلزم مثل القوات من المناطق
الحضاريه بما في ذلك منازل المدنيين
الخارجيه الامريكيه اكدت ان تمديد الهدنه
التي كانت بدايتها في العشرين من مايو
سيوفر المزيد من الوقت لايجاد حل توافقي
بين حمدوك والبرهانه الذين يتهمان او
يتهمان بعضهما البعض بخرق الهدنه التي كان
من المفترض ان تفسح المجال لفتح ممرات
امنه للمدنيين هذا طبعا وهنا طبعا
السعوديه والولايات المتحده الطرفين على
احترام الالتزامات بالامتناع عن اي
انتهاكات خلال فتره التمديد الجديده خصوصا
وان هذا التمديد تقتضي او يقتضي اتفاق
الطرفين على مناقشه وقف اطلاق النار طويل
الامد والذي يستلزم ايضا اخلاء القوات من
المناطق الحضاريه بما في ذلك منازل
المدنيين وتمكين الموظفين الحكوميين من
استئنافي عملهم المكونان العسكريان اكد
عزمهما احترام شروط التمديد بما في ذلك
تسليم المزيد من المساعدات الانسانيه
وتسهيل اصلاح الخدمات الاساسيه واخلاء
الجهات المسلحه من المستشفيات المتحدث
باسم العمليه السياسيه عمر يوسف دعا اطراف
الهدنه بالالتزام الصارم بنصوصها مضيفا
انه من المهم ان تنقل الاطراف المدنيه
والعسكريه عن خطابات الاستقطاب والتحشيد
وان تعود لخيار السلامه نناقش هذا الموضوع
مع ضيوف طيب بس هنا صحفي السوداني اهلا بك
من الرياض الصحفي كذلك فتح الرحمن يوسف
اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا
من لندن معك سيد الطيب سيد الطيب السؤال
المطروح الى اي مدى هناك قدره على التزام
بهذا الهدنه
ولما نطرح هذا السؤال نستذكر كذلك تصريح
عبد الفتاح البرهان الذي اكد فيه بانه
قوات الدعم السريع ان لم تلتزم وان لم
تنصع لهذه الهدنه فسيكون هناك تحرك مميت
وقاسي كما قال في تصريحته الاخيره هل يمكن
للدعم السريع ان يلتزم بهذه الهدنه بحسب
رايك
بدايه احييك اهلا مشاهدين
وايضا شكرا للصداقه فيما يتعلق بالهدنه
الهدنه وكل الجوانب هي مطلوبه من كل
الغرافيه مطلوبه
لتامين الامن يعني تمكين المواطنين
والعالقين والجرحى والمصابين من الخروج من
مناطق العمليات لكن عمليا هذه الهدنه لا
يمكن ان تحقق اهدافها نتيجه لاصرار
الانقلابيين بقياده البرهان
يعني الاستمرار في الحال يعني قطعه طريقه
على اي يعني مساهمه او اي فكره او اي
مشروع او اي جهد انساني جهد دولي وهذا
طبعا يرتبط
بالخطه الاستراتيجيه
البرهان هي التي تؤكد على الالتزام
بالهدنه سيد يوسف ما رايك في هذا الكلام
هل عبد الفتاح الورهان مع حفظ الالقاب
طبعا كما يقول ضيفي هو الذي قطع الطريق
على النجاح هذه الهدى
طيب شكرا جزيلا
تحياتي لك وتحيته للمشاهدين الاعزاء للاسف
الشديد نحن الان لا نتحدث عن الانقلابيين
ونتحدث عن كانما هو يتحدث عن يعني طرف اخر
شرعي جاء به الشعب السوداني لقوات الدعم
يا رجل نحن نتحدث عن المؤسسه العسكريه
القوميه
الجيش السوداني التي تاسست من قبل 100 عام
نواتها قوه الدفاع السودان التي لا بوجبه
السودان استقلاله بمشاركتها في الحرب
العالميه
نحن نتحدث هنا عن الايقوبات الجيش
السوداني قوات الشعب السودانيه ونتحدث عن
قواتنا السريعه التي هي الان للاسف الشديد
هي الان يعني اصلا هي تمارس خروقات مستمره
في حق الانسان والانسانيه في الخرطوم
وحواليها المناطق الاشتباكات لانها تحتل
المواقع الاساسيه
لبني ادم في السودان يعني هناك مستشفيات
تم تحويلها الى سكنات عسكريه والى مواقع
للقنص وهناك يعني بيوت سبعه واربعين الف
بيت في الخرطوم في الخرطوم بحري الخرطوم
تم احتلالها بشكل فظيع من قبل
ونحن نتحدث مريح صنعته قوات الدعم السريع
بهذا الشكل المفهوم كلام حضرتك ولكن بهذا
الشكل نحن نعود لنقطه البدايه كل طرف يتهم
الطرف المقابل
بخرقه للهدنه بعدم الالتزام بها بعدم
احترامها وبالتالي ما الذي يمكن ان نفهم
سيد الطيب يعني هناك تصريحات من الجنرانين
ولكن على ارض الواقع
الافعال مخالفه ولا نعلم من المتورط في
عدم احترام هذه الهدن
كويس بدايه انا يعني اعلق على كلام ضيفك
الذي قال ان قوات الدعم السريع هي قوات
يعني يبدو من حديث غير شرعيه هذه القوات
جاءت من القوات المسلحه اذا هو مفترض من
القوات المسلحه هي عند شرعيه فهذه القوات
وهذا الدعم السريع هي فصيل من فصائل
المسلحه فيبقى كلامه مجافي للحقيقه يعني
لم تنزل من كوكب اخر ولم تاتي من من
اوروبا ولا من اي قاره انما هي قوات
سودانيه
وتم تاسيسها
بقوانين النظام السابق فيبقى مخالفه يعني
اصلا الدعم السريعيه قوات وطنيه والا يبقى
الوطنيه هي حكرا على جهه معينه في السودان
لكن اذا كانت المواطنين لكل ابناء فهؤلاء
وطنيون سودانيون دفعوا ارواحا ودماءا من
اجل السودان ومن حقهم ان يكون لهم راي
فيما يجري البرهان اختطف اراده الشعب
السوداني غير الحكومه الديمقراطيه
والحكومه المدنيه التي جاهدت بها الثوره
وفرط نفسه على الشعب السوداني وحينما خرجت
الدعم السريع على ارادته واعترفت بان هناك
انقلابا يعني قاد البلاد الى المستنقع
التخلف والخراب والدمر عندها
اعلنوا اعلنوا ان قوات الدعم السريع قوات
متواتره وقالوا انها قوات جندويل وما الى
ذلك وهذه المصطلحات وهذه الشعارات هي تعبر
عن عقليه عنصريه بمعنى انه هي يصفون يعني
كل يعني المكونات العربيه في السودان او
اعتبارهم
غير صحيح
ولكن يقال
في السودان خلينا نسمع تعليق الاستاذ يوسف
اذا سمحت اولا هو تحدث عن القوات الدعم
السريعه يقول هي هي تكونت بطريقه شرعيه
وهي فصيل اصيل
دستوريه من من قبل قوات الد الشعب
السوداني اللي هي قوات الجيش نعم صحيح
ولكنها هي تمرست عليه يعني دستورين هي
الارض
لو سمحت يا طيب
لو سمحت انا ما قاطعتك خليني اكمل مقاطعتك
ما اقاطعك اصلا يعني المحور الثاني يتحدث
ايضا هو يعني بالاضافه الى انه يتكلم عن
شرعيه تكلم يتكلم على
وتدعم السريع خرجت لتدين انقلاب 25 ابريل
طيب اذا كان هي هي لماذا ادانت لماذا
تاخرت في الادانه لماذا من البدايه كانت
هي في فندق واحد مع البرهان يا اخي خليني
اكمل يا سيد الطيب لو سمحت يا اخي انا ما
قاعد اقاطعك يا اخي خليني اكمل الفكره لو
خليني اكمل الفكره لو سمحت لو سمحت ارجوك
ارجوك
لانه انتهى الوقت اكمل الحديث يعني انا
اتحدث عن انه هو المساله الخروج على 25
ابريل هو لانه حصل غزل بينه وبين بعض قوات
الحريه والتغيير وهم الان يعني يعملون
بمنهجيه مغفل نافع هم اصلا القوات الدعم
السريع ستنفرض فيما بعد بعد
تصل الى هي موقعها من خلال الدعم السريع
وكبديل لقوات الجيش ولن يحصل ذلك هذا هذا
الوقت
اولا على ان يدرك
المقاله الذي ستؤول اليه السوداء البلاد
اذا ما استمرت هذه الحرب انا اقول بهذا من
هذه
القناه
الموقره ان الشعب السوداني يتطلع الى وقف
الحرب والى اعاده المسار المدني
الديمقراطي ومحاكمه المجرمين الذين
اختطفوا اراده الشعب السوداني باسم القوات
المسلحه اختطفوها
2021 في كل الحالات 89
وفتح الرحمن يوسف الصحفيه السوداني كذلك
شكرا لكم السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات